still morning right just barely how are
we I hope you're enjoying this NDC event
I am so happy that NDC has come to the
United States I've been doing NDC events
for years in Europe and I always thought
they were one of the best conferences
around so I was really happy and honored
to be part of this event so today's
topic is an opinionated opinionated
approach to asp.net core this is
basically where I sat down after a
couple code reviews and said you know
we're doing some interesting things in
these projects I'd like to jot down some
ideas of things that we've done right
and things that we've done wrong and I
came up with a list of something like 61
items and I thought well if I can cut it
down to an even 50 maybe I could make a
conference talk out of it so that's what
you're going to hear today we're going
to cover topics like mmm organizing your
solutions and projects organizing your
startup code working with controllers
working with Razer pages also how to
organize client code a couple tips for
writing c-sharp code in the.net core
environment and working with views and
razor pages so I do assume that you know
a little bit about asp.net core maybe
you're already working on a project
maybe you're planning to start a project
and if so I hope that these tips help
you
so we'll start about solutions from
projects first oh also some testing tips
some of my personal philosophy and maybe
some rants towards the end solutions and
projects you know there's this really
interesting thing if you go out onto
github and you look at project
structures how things are laid out
inside of a github repository across
various technologies across node and
across ruby and people that are doing
pure spa's and microsoft repositories
for dotnet core code you'll start to
notice a consistent project structure
that i've adopted for my project so if
you look at pretty much well if you look
at any microsoft repository related to
dotnet core or asp.net core your Garant
is guaranteed to see a few things at the
top level of that project which is
you're always going to see a source
folder underneath of there I know
that all of the CS proj files all of the
projects that make up this solution this
new get package whatever we're putting
together inside of this repo they're all
going to live inside of there there's
always going to be a test folder where
all the unit testing projects live if
this repository represents some sort of
library that people are going to use
there's typically a samples directory
that shows you a few different ways to
consume this library and work with the
api's there's typically some build
scripts checked in at the top level
there might be some benchmarks if it's a
performance sensitive piece and I like
this repository structure it's something
I've adopted for my projects it takes a
little bit of work inside a visual
studio I'll give you a tip for that in
just a second but if you can mimic that
repository structure inside a visual
studio when I actually look at the
solution inside a visual studio it
encourages developers to follow that
structure so docks
might be another top-level folder that
you have for a project of course one
challenge to this is that we know that
the solution Explorer in Visual Studio
is a complete fabrication of what
actually exists on disks right the
solution Explorer lives it doesn't
actually show us the physical file
system layout but and what do I mean by
that I mean if I come into now don't do
this audit advance on me please this is
not a pub comp presentation if I come
into Visual Studio and I'm looking at
the regular solution Explorer view and I
tell this to add a new folder that's not
adding a folder on my desk where are we
here have to back out a little bit
adding a new solution folder creates a
virtual folder that the solution file
understands but it doesn't create
something on disk so I can create this
new solution folder it's not going to
show up on file system it's not going to
show up in my repository I can add items
into it they're just gonna be dumped
into the root of the project however
Visual Studio 2017 up here in the
action toolbar a visual studio of the
solution Explorer there is this little
thing to switch over and to a solutions
and folders view and when I click on
that now I have a view of the file
system just like what I would have in
Visual Studio code its presenting the
truth so if I right-click a folder and I
say please add another folder it
actually adds something to the file
system of that folder so it has some
advantages and disadvantages and you
might find yourself toggling back and
forth between the solution view and the
folder view the folder view is great
when you want to create a folder on the
file system you want to add some files
to it so here I have a script folder
which I'll talk about just a bit I
encourage people to add scripts to their
project and check them into the
repository but some of the things I lose
like if I try to right-click on a
project if I like right clicking to
manage NuGet packages and right-clicking
to do different things with my project
all those project options are going
because now it's just kind of a folder
but you can toggle back and forth
depending on what what you want to
achieve at the moment so I can right
click now and get to manage and you get
packages some other things that you
might consider checking in include
samples and tools so here's the great
thing about Microsoft open sourcing
things there was never a problem if I
wanted to see the Microsoft source code
for let's say system about string or
something that was built into the dotnet
framework there was always decompiler
tools that I could use to dig into code
that they wrote for asp.net or anything
so having that code now be open source
on github
yes it's an advantage I don't have to
work quite as hard to see the code that
they wrote the big advantage to me is
the other things that you find inside of
those github repositories for asp.net
core and dotnet core and core FX the
samples folder so when I was trying to
understand asp.net security and what was
happening at a lower level I went into
the github repo asp.net slash security
and I found the samples folder and lo
and behold inside of there were just
these somewhat thrown together samples
of things you would never do in
production
but they were very revealing of how this
how the middleware and how the services
worked for things like asp.net cookie
authentication so you dig into the
cookie sample and you'll see an example
of different configuration options and
what the middle way is supposed to do
and what it's not supposed to do the
other thing that is extremely valuable
inside of those github repositories are
the unit tests because again you can
read through the unit test and find
testing tips from Microsoft how do they
test stuff like middleware and also you
can look at what a service and what a
piece of middleware supposed to do by
reading the unit test so those are all
very valuable and things we didn't have
access to before I also like to include
development scripts so with that net
core we have a command-line interface
that can do all sorts of interesting
things
we can use it to add package references
and with the entity framework and it can
create migrations of deep databases if
you're developing for some sort of cloud
platform like an EWS or a sure it's very
useful to have scripts checked in so
that when developers clone the
repository they'll know that there is a
script in there to set up a development
environment for example we'll go out to
Azure and set up an app service and a
sequel database and give it some default
parameters for them to start working so
I always include development scripts oh
and one other thing the solution file
the dot SLN file it's nice to keep that
in the root of the repository that way
you can clone a repository and just
double click that right away I don't
have to go searching for it and I
couldn't open up the solution but here's
an example of an ad migration script
that has checked in so a developer can
just say add migration add employee
feature or edit invoice feature and what
that will do is go over to the data
project run EF migrations to add a new
migration automatically update my
database and then put me back into the
folder that I was in before with a pop
so it just kind of makes things a little
bit easier deployment scripts and
templates depending on what cloud
environment you're working in there's
various different ways to approach the
provisioning of a development or QA
environment
I use Azure quite a bit so one of the
things that we'll do is usually check in
a script file that you can run that will
execute an azure resource manager
template which is a Jason file which
includes all the configuration
information for setting up a resource
group in fact in Visual Studio there's
resource group projects that you can
create they'll automatically generates
some PowerShell scripts for you and some
templates that you can modify inside of
Visual Studio to like set up an app
service set up a sequel server set up an
azure key ball wire up all the
configuration settings they look kind of
like this this would be an example of
going to the automation script inside of
the azure portal and say generate one of
me generate for me a resource manager
template that I can then check in the
source control and that resource manager
template describes the resources I have
created and all their configuration
entries unfortunately they're
frustrating to work with any one use
resource manager templates a couple yeah
it's amazing you can go and do a sure
you can set up let's say a virtual
machine or an app service you can do
these things then you can come to
automation script and you can have as
your generate the script that is
supposed to create that resource and in
my experience they only round-trip about
80% of the time sometimes you have to go
back in and tweak things and the
documentation it's not that good and you
get strange error messages but when
things are automated and they're working
well it's a truly wonderful experience
another option for a sure would be the
azure CLI that it can create virtual
machines and delete virtual machines and
sequel servers and app services so we
check them and what about builds some of
the projects that I create use out there
which basically gives me a free build
engine for open source projects if I
have something out there where I want to
create a new get package inside of out
there I can tell it where and github is
the source code that it should pull down
when I do a push or a pull request where
is the source code where's the source
code live that it should pull down and
then I give a build instructions and I
can either describe the build
instructions in a UI by selecting check
boxes and saying do this and do that or
I can check in a gamo file so my general
recommendation when you use these build
systems that try to be GUI driven is to
get as much out of the GUI as you can
and try to put it into scripts or some
sort of configuration file so for
example with out there if I check in an
app there yeah Moe file into the
rudiment repository that gives out there
all the instructions it needs to do a
build and one of the things I can tell
it when it does a build is to use a
build script that I also have checked in
so build PS one typically dotnet core
applications are pretty straightforward
to build this would be an example of a
PowerShell script that basically does
dotnet restore net build dotnet run the
tests and then dotnet pack to create the
nougat package so the advantage to this
is if a build is not working and out
there and I don't have a script I'm just
relying on that Bayer UI to do things
for me it's very difficult for me to
debug I can't run the OP Nayyar build
locally at least with this I can rub
that I can run this PowerShell script
locally on my machine and it should
produce the same result as when it's
inside of a player running same thing
goes for vsti so if you use visual
studio team services you're probably
aware that you can create a build
definition and inside of a build
definition you can drag and drop these
different tasks and arrange them and
configure them to do the same things
that we just saw on the ps1 script so do
it not never store do a dotnet build on
a test on that publish publish the
artifacts some of those steps are not
things that you can easily replicate in
a local development environment things
like publish the web artifact because
that's actually taking a zip file and
putting it into VST s somewhere where
you can download it later but certainly
not never stored not net building a test
out not published not necessarily I need
something and I don't necessarily need
to describe those steps inside of a GUI
so an alternative would be to use from
the tax catalog a simple PowerShell task
or command line tasks or custom tasks
that you can get from the V STS
marketplace that know how to run build
scripts like PI sake or cake cake if you
haven't heard of it as a gives you the
ability to
c-sharp to write build definitions to
write build tasks using c-sharp code so
it's familiar and you can run that same
cake or P sake or command line script on
your turbo on the machine and also
inside of the STS and that makes your
builds a little bit easier to debug as
well as source controlling what's
actually happening so let's get out of
some of the Moonbeam stuff and talk
about startup code so and doing code
reviews when I open up a project one of
the first places I look is inside a
startup Nazi ass because we know that
for asp.net core that's what defines
what services are going to be registered
with the asp.net core container that
describes what little where's in effect
for doing HTTP processing and to me
that's all start up top CS should be
responsible for it basically describes
how is the application going to behave
at runtime but when I open up startup CS
sometimes I see some some of the most
bizarre things that people are doing
I've seen people see databases and run
database migrations and move files
around on the filesystem copy you know
make sure their CSS files are copied out
of some folder and put into dub-dub-dub
root things like that to me there's
better places to put that kind of logic
if you insist on having that logic
inside of your application and we'll
talk about where that is but to me
there's three responsibilities inside of
startup startup not see us
there's the constructor you can do some
limited work inside of the constructor
if you want to inject some services like
the hosting environment or I
configuration and save that off as a
field to use later
there's configure services to configure
the service provider aka the container
inside of asp.net core and there's
configure where you can receive an app
builder as well as other injected
dependencies to define your middleware
that's all you want to do so in asp.net
core 2.0 if I open our programmer up see
us I actually like to get as many things
out of the way as possible before we
even get to the startup constructor so
if you want to configure some logging
and things like that that would be best
to do inside of the main method in fact
if we
at a different project here program to
see us maybe you know by now but you
scaffold out an asp.net core 2.0
application this create default builder
does a number of things for you
including setting up some default
application configuration sources so it
goes ahead and registers app settings
Jason and app settings dock development
Jason as configuration sources and also
configures kestrel would also configures
a console logger so if anything goes
wrong things spit out into the console a
lot of the stuff like that logging and
so forth is taken care of for you before
you even get into startup so to me
startup these days is really about two
things first of all there's services so
inside of configure services I have
sometimes seen hundreds of lines of code
because people want to use the MVC
services but customize them a bit so
they'll add some code to do things maybe
like this so 10-15 lines of code to
customize some of the MVC options to add
different conventions to change the
locations and so forth but you can
imagine if there's this block of code to
configure that MVC services and then you
add some additional code inside of
configure services to configure or
entity framework and to configure
asp.net identity configure services
becomes very cumbersome to look at and
try to figure out what's going on so I
always encourage people to keep this
method flat all I want to see is a list
of things that you're doing
oh you're adding MVC you're adding some
security services you're using mediator
you're adding some data stores and if
I'm interested in some specific details
like what are you doing to customize NBC
I can just put the cursor on that line
press f12 and I can look at exactly what
you're doing but this is a good big
picture of you which is what I want to
see inside of configure services I don't
actually want to see all the little
configuration details
same thing for configure which is
setting up little where although I do
believe it's okay to have an elf
statement inside of there so I just want
to be able to see oh you're in
development so we'll use the developer
exception page and database err page and
browser link which no one uses anymore
it's on the slog otherwise we use this
exception handler and then they'll
probably be a string of a little way of
beneath that and and again most pieces
of middleware
allow you to pass in options to specify
some different behaviors for example the
static files middleware can pass in
options to tell it what physical direct
directory to look in and so forth but if
I'm going to have any of those options
inside of configure again I want to
write an extension method for I
application builder so I can just see
something that says use static files
with options right and those options are
tucked off as details somewhere else and
I can see exactly what middleware is in
the project and what order that little
wire is executing and then what about
all this other stuff so what if you want
to run any framework migrations what if
you do need to copy files for some
strange reason what if you want to seed
the database with data well it's really
interesting that asp.net core what we're
creating is a console application you
know if I do a dotnet run I am running a
process from the console that standalone
and what's interesting about that
process is there's this point in time
after I've asked the web host builder to
build me a host and before I call run
which is when it starts opening or
listening for socket connections to come
in and prompts us HTTP messages there's
this period of time right in here where
I have a fully configured application
all the services and all the
configuration options that I've pumped
into the application are there we know
about our app settings we have our
connection strings we know which
services were going to use in production
and so if I want to execute some code at
that point to do something like seed the
database then the main method of program
dot C S or somewhere inside of program
dot C is between build and run that's a
good place to call out and do things
because I can take advantage of all this
knowledge that I have so here's an
example I want to process some DB
commands looking at the incoming
command-line arguments and using my host
so that I can get the services and
connection strings and things that are
configured here's a piece of code
that might be easier to come over to
visual studio and look at that here's a
piece of code that'll basically say okay
if someone did a dotnet run on my
application and passed in an argument
drop dB what we're going to do is use
our services to get a DB context and
make sure the database is deleted and if
they passed in drop DB space migrate DB
will also did it get a DB context and
tell it to run the current migrations
which could even create a database from
scratch and if they also typed in C DB
we can add some initial data that's
tucked away inside of that application
somewhere and I just want to point out
that all of this is inside of a using
statement where we get an I service
scoped Factory and tell it to create a
scope and that's very important if
you're ever going to go directly to the
service provider inside of asp.net core
and ask it to resolve a service which is
what happens down here so dear service
provider give me B DB context derived
class so I can work worked with the
database if you ever do this outside of
the scope of an HTTP transaction you
have to be very careful that you don't
accidentally create a singleton which is
what will happen if you don't explicitly
get a service scope factory tell it and
tell it to create a scope which gives
you back a service provider that you can
use to resolve services but when you
dispose it you can clean everything off
make sure that goes away so how would
this get used well I could write a
little script that a developer can do
call execute called recreate DB so when
I arrived to the office in the morning
and I do a git pull to get the latest
source code the people who've checked in
I don't know if there's new migrations
or new sets of test data or what is it
so I'll just do a git pull and then
recreate DB and it'll run my application
drop it migrate it see the database and
then stop it will not listen for sockets
at that point so that makes life a
little bit easier let's talk about
project structure I have an extremely
difficult time these days looking at a
traditional asp.net MVC project that has
like controllers folder and a views
folder and a models folder to me it
drives me insane let me show you let me
try to demonstrate that by let's pretend
for a minute so over here I have created
a new project web application 35 I'm
about to do some work on it you know we
just came out of a sprint meeting and
someone has told me that the register or
the reset password users are not able to
reset passwords and I need to go in to
go into this application and look at
that bug so this application was
generated by doing family project asking
for an MVC project and setting the
authentication options equal to
individual authentication so it's using
asp.net identity and it spit out a bunch
of user interface code that allows users
to register and log in and log out
change the password reset their password
etc etc but now it's my responsibility
to work on this feature what everyone
else in the company thinks of as a
feature to reset a password so hmm let
me start with the controller is it in
the account controller or the manage
controller I don't know but how bad
could it be to just look through one of
these let's start actually at the very
top of this file that line one okay here
I can see we're going to login login
with two-factor authentication mm-hmm
maybe I just should have done a finding
files lock out register external login
[Music]
what's going on confirm email forgot
password oh here we go all the way down
here at line 392 reset password this
must be the area that I went to work in
okay so next let me find the model that
this is working with because maybe the
problem something with the validation
with the model I guess that's in the
models folder so I have to come over
here I apologize if you can't see the
solution Explorer but I found the view
model okay there's the D model now I
have to find the view mmm
so we have to jump over to the views
folder and fortunately yeah I can see
under the account folder there is a
recessed reset password view and finally
I haven't even got to the unit test yet
but finally I might be able to work on
this bug where there's a problem with
reset password that just drives me
insane the model-view-controller design
pattern tells us that we should have a
separation of concerns between the model
the view and the controller the
controller receives an HTTP request the
controller uses some services to build a
model the model doesn't know anything
about HTTP doesn't know anything about
the use the controller takes that model
can hand it off to a view and the view
has the logic to render that model so
there's a separation of concerned but no
one ever said that there had to be a
physical separation between the
abstractions in that design pattern
where we had to put them into three
different directories so for the last oh
I'd say year and a half I've been using
a concept known as feature folders so
with feature folders you can organize
folders however you want
you might even organize it organize them
hierarchically like your UI is organized
so when I when I go into the application
there's an admin link and I click on
that and there's a menu open that allows
me to manage this and manage that and
manage seasons and oh you know now when
I'm trying to work on a feature that
someone has identified in the
application I'm kind of following the
same logic when I navigate through these
folders and lo lo and behold here's my
controller ant in that folder I just
open it up there's some views associated
with it I can open that up and there are
some models and they're all in the same
folder still a separation of concern
it's just not a physical separation of
the abstractions and to me it's it's a
much easier way to organize MVC
applications and find things and work on
things and actually work on features
this would be maybe how we could start
reorganizing the account controller
breaking it out into smaller pieces and
maybe having a registry set password
controller folder inside of here
to do this it's very easy I actually
have a nougat package or just OD code
feature folders you can install that
actually the command you'd probably want
to use today is net and package OD code
feature folders and then configure
services you can just add NBC
and feature folders to that service
it'll configure your NBC options to use
those that being said these days I quite
like Ranger pages who's using razor
pages who knows about razor pages okay
when I first when razor pages first came
out I and I think many other people
looked at and said oh this is gonna be
one of those two simplistic things that
Microsoft has come up with that I never
want to actually use but then when I
actually started digging into it I
realized razor pages are exactly what I
want when I went to generate HTML so I'm
gonna walk you through a couple razor
page scenarios just to show you what I
think are the advantages but to me if
I'm building an API that has to return
JSON or XML I'm not generating HTML I'm
building an API that's when I use MVC
controllers if I'm generating HTML from
the server I don't want to controller
with the view I want to use a razor page
so over here in Visual Studio I just
want to show you that as an alternative
to web application 35 with all those
huge 500 line controllers and
controllers and views are in different
places I also have web application 36
new an improved version of web
application 35 but this one was
generated using file new project and
selecting asp.net core razor pages and
individual authentication so instead of
generating huge controllers it has now
generated a series of razor pages and
now when someone comes to me and says
hey there's a bug with the users
resetting passwords what are you going
to do about it
what I will do after I close all these
things up here
let's not save anything what I will do
is say oh let's go into pages I guess
that would be under account and let me
look through here oh here's a reset
password the razor page let me click to
open that and here's reset pay password
the code-behind
or page model for that razor page and
tada I now have everything opened that I
need to work on that feature so to me
razor pages are a lot like
folders I don't need to use feature
folders if I'm building stuff of
features with razor pages so what are
they exactly yes a razor page is still
just a razor view has a CS HTML
extension uses tag helpers uses model
binding you can render sections you can
use layout pages you start all those
things that you usually do with range
reviews the difference is it's going to
have a page model or code behind file
behind it which some people think oh my
gosh maybe it's too much like web forms
but it's not there's still the
separation of concerns there's still
dependency injection so you can see when
I would need to reset a user password I
can have a constructor and ask for
dependencies like a user manager or a
logger or dbcontext or I hosting
environment I can I'm not a big fan of
this but I can define my input model I
can define input models and output
models and have this razor page work
with them when a user posts something to
my razor page I can tell asp.net core
that I want to try to receive posted
form values into this property input so
that's how I can receive things like the
user's email and their password and
their confirm password but one get
method responds to a get request but one
post method responds to a post requests
there's no synthetic click events or any
funny stuff like that so to me this is
just as good as having a controller and
using a controller to render a view just
things are organized a little bit
differently plus razor pages have some
some advantages over controllers like
one of the features they added to razor
pages is that they will automatically
validate anti forgery tokens on a forum
posts you don't have to worry about
developers accidentally forgetting the
validate anti forgery token attribute on
a controller action they will do that
for me because they just assume
everything's going to be a forum post
when there's a post so razor page is
good give them a try controllers
I do not allow people inside of start-up
t us to say app dot use NBC and then
write that little lambda expression that
takes a route builder and define routes
inside of you know the conventional
routes inside of start-up Nazi ass you
know the conventional route would be
something like controller slash action
slash the optional ID parameter when
people rely on those routes and inside
of start-up CS they build horrible
horrible looking api's they don't think
about the URLs they don't think about
parameter names I want everyone and I
encourage everyone to use route
parameters because with route parameters
develop alert developers are much more
likely to say we know actually this this
piece of the API it's part of the admin
section or the admin feature of our API
so let me put a literal admin in front
of this so admin / manage something and
then some action perhaps and I don't
know if you've ever worked on one of
those MVC projects where every single
action parameter was named ID you ever
done that ever had that even if it was
something like invoice date right if
someone's passing in an invoice date and
they'll still call it ID drives me
insane so the routing the route
attributes also encourage people to
think about the parameter names and what
they should be called and what they
should be mean for the actual action so
instead of having an ID because I'm just
being lazy and relying on the
conventional route to find this out of
Starbucks yes I'm actually thinking this
is a seasoned ID versus a matchset ID
and my actions become a little bit
clearer to me so I encourage you to use
the route attributes and throw away the
other forms of routing this one I'm
still I was big one mediator and now I'm
backing off for a little bit on that how
many people use mediator anyway whew
it's a very simple in-memory message
boss what it allows me to do is inside
of a controller action I can remove
pretty much all of my logic inside of a
controller action and instead what I
want to do is put together either a
command or a query so in this case I'm
putting together a command
command is actually just based on the
inputs that the user has typed into a
form I'm gonna accept those inputs as a
command and I'm going to tell mediator
to send this command off somewhere in a
system that's actually going to process
it and produce some result for me so all
of the all of the logic and the services
and the things that go into logging in a
user are completely removed from the
controller there's somewhere in a
request handler that I've defined for
that specific type login user commune so
the good news is that means some logic
becomes a lot easier to reuse its
packaged away instead of a component
that's not coupled to your UI or to a
controller at all it's also easy with
mediator to introduce things like
decorators so if I want this command to
flow through a pipeline something
that'll log it and something that will
validate it and then something that'll
actually execute the login that's
relatively easy to do with mediator and
I can plug and plug things in but that
being said there's always downsides
right so a lot of people will look at it
and say that's just another layer of
abstraction and what you're doing is
you're making it harder for me to work
on the login user feature because I
don't know where that goes so you have
to decide based on your team and based
on the type of application you're
building and how much flexibility you
need and how much were you usability you
need whether it's whether or not to use
mediator but it's good for specific
scenarios the other thing I tell people
is don't build projects anymore that
have an API have API endpoints inside of
it and also have endpoints that render
HTML and take form posts at least don't
do it if you're using any form of cookie
authentication because as soon as you
have cookie authentication you have the
risk of a cross-site request forgery and
a lot of people don't realize that they
have to protect from cross-site request
forgeries and they're api's so in order
to do that one of the things we have to
do is get anti forgery tokens down to
our JavaScript so that when we make Ajax
calls or use the fetch API we can pass
along an HTTP header that includes an
anti forgery token and this is just a
simple code example of an endpoint you
could build that javascript could invoke
to get the anti forgery token
needs to send along so just inject the
int for jury service and what this get
request will do is use that service to
get in-store tokens it's not obvious but
getting stor tokens actually does two
things one thing I will do is return a
data structure that has the anti forgery
token inside of it and also has the
header name the JavaScript should use
when it sends that token along so we
will take that data structure and
serialize it back and send it down to
JavaScript so it can use that token and
write the appropriate header but the
other side effect that happens here
that's not obvious is that if the anti
forgery token cookie has not been set
into the browser yet when I call getting
stored tokens I ante forgery did the
default implementation of III and set
forgery will issue that cookie so at
that point I could start using follow
the anti forgery token on my API
endpoints typically not something you
want to do if you you know if you can
separate them you don't have to worry
about that type of thing
security policies if you're just coming
in to asp.net core and you're wondering
how authorization works and how you can
write authorization attributes to work
with roles and Active Directory groups
and things like that excuse me that
could be an entire day workshop an
entire day of a workshop but basically
things boil everything in asp.net core
boils down to claims so I can build a
claims principle to define a user and
add claims to that principle saying this
is the first name this is their email
address this is a role that they're in
like admin or the department that
they're in which is sales and once that
is there when I went to authorize that
user to do something I can look at
claims and these again so claimed can
represent roles they can represent facts
about me they might represent
permissions that I have so a claim could
be is can edit invoices that could be a
claim and the way I evaluate claims the
easy way to evaluate those is to use an
authorization policy builder and when I
have a policy builder there's a fluent
API where I can say require this require
that and require a claim like it is
admin with this value
and when I build that policy I can then
use it and give it a mean and I could
build I could say authorized that
authorized attribute is admin or I could
wrap it up into a custom attribute user
is admin what that'll do is it's
basically the authorized attribute
saying evaluate the policy is admin
which checks for the claim is admin
hopefully that's making sense security
policies are very easy once you know
that they're there and you know
everything is working on clean talk
about views for a second
don't use HTML helpers anymore they're
hideous and they were always the worst
part with espn/abc use tag helpers if
you're not already so things like ESP -
for a SP - validation summary those are
good but easy to read they're also
extensible you can build your own tag
helper by deriving from a base class tag
helper and implementing a process method
they're relatively straightforward for
most trivial tag helpers use view
components view components are like
partial views but they get to render
things independently so a view component
is like a controller in the sense that
you can give it a constructor and you
can enjoy inject services into it but it
doesn't respond to a request it has to
be rendered from some other view so
interview I can say actually this way
with a tag helper I can say go out and
render the view component main menu this
main menu is a class with an invoked
method so we can have logic in there it
can do data access and it can say return
of you and that view could be whatever
markup you need with whatever model and
that's a good way to build composable
you is if you need to client-side code
so everyone's using some form of angular
or typescript or react these days and my
favorite tool to build that sort of
thing is web pack I'm not going to go
into a lot of detail on this since I
think there's some other talks this week
on web pack but this is an example web
pack configuration file
ah so the thing I wanted to point out
about webpack as I've seen a lot of
developers struggle with that webpack
configuration file and the trick is
don't think of webpack config KS as a
typical configuration file it's not a
JSON file it's not static inert data
it's actually a JavaScript module that
webpack the tool will load up an X cube
so you can put executable code in there
if you need more flexibility so for
example if I need web pack to go out and
find tight strip files that are kind of
scattered across feature folders I can
actually write some JavaScript code that
gets executed inside a node to say let's
go out and lob up all the TS files spec
TS files so these are unit test
specifications grab them from all the
feature folders and put them into an
array for me as well as all the specs
that are in this client folder I'm not
gonna talk about JavaScript services
that much that was another Steve
Sanderson creation though but that
basically allows you to use webpack hot
reloads integrated into asp.net core
middleware so that when you send a
request to your asp.net core application
asp.net core can work with web pack to
compile all your typescript files bundle
them into a JavaScript file put them in
the browser and then as you make changes
to your JavaScript and save it those
changes can be compiled and
automatically swapped into the browser
for you the hot module replacement I'm a
big fan of con emu anyone use con Meo or
commander so once you start working with
some of these command line tools when
you're writing some command line scripts
you'll know you'll realize the basic
Windows command line is sometimes a
little bit deficient so I use con mu so
a couple different things I can do here
one is I can right click and say create
another console for me and have it's
hard to save it here but let me look
down here at the bottom tab consoles
which is very useful when you have a
long-running task in one
I can also do things like this see if I
have a setup to work today
where are we
github you release rips yeah so I just
typed J s command because inside of this
project there's a bunch of things that
happen to have to happen with JX and
things aren't quite configured correctly
but ideally on the left hand side here I
think I just ran it from the wrong
folder it's all um this would be running
web pack watch up here would be running
web pack unit test or running unit tests
on my app down here would be running a
karma integration task and I'd be able
to have all three windows open and all
those things running at the same time
and if I write some typescript code and
save the file and it fails a unit test I
would see some red scroll by and that
would be glorious that does that all
happen for me let me try to go to see if
I get this working real quick what
folder am I in
this might be a little bit better yeah
over here is the webpack watch over here
we're still failing so you get the idea
the command that does all that for
Connie M you would be to run Connie mu
with this following run list in one
window I went to run npm run watch then
in another window npm run test watch put
that in a new window that split
horizontally that's SH and then NPN run
karma unit test in a new console that
split vertically so it takes this side
that was split horizontally and splits
it vertically and I get that window in
the bottom bottom rate fascinating right
I'm gonna skip over a few slides here
related to client food I do want to
point out look Bauer is dead just use
NPM or yarn for client-side stuff even
if you're just you know if you're not
yeah you're not writing a node.js
application I understand you're just
using bootstrap and jQuery but you know
all those front-end dependencies now
they're all in NPM so forget about these
other package managers in qiyam or yarn
will do just fine for you to download
those and manage those a new get for
anything dotnet related I was not a big
fan I tried to like type script for so
long and it wasn't until I'd say
beginning of 2017 where I thought it
really started to mesh well with the way
JavaScript programmers wanted to work
and I really started to enjoy tight
script and now I do encourage people to
take a look at it if they haven't looked
at it yet type Spirit just finally
embrace the node ecosystem you can npm
install a typescript compiler the
typescript compiler will do things like
use the node module resolution strategy
in the way it tracks directories and
looks around and then it understands the
node modules folder so when you npm
install other things and inside of
typescript you import them it knows to
look in there this paths configuration
option so this is a typescript config
file the pass option is very useful when
you want to go and define your own
custom sort of modules folder so I don't
want I don't want to
forced to put my typescript files in a
specific folder I want to be able to put
them someplace and tell typescript look
if something doesn't import through from
bar then one of the places where you
should look for something called bar is
in the client slash script folder so you
go into there and look for it and that's
what that would do
so typescript has come a long way but
most projects where I have to do any
amount of typescript or JavaScript I'll
have the project open in two editors
visual sphere for c-sharp code and
Visual Studio code for typescript and
es2015 it was still by far the best
editor for typescript and JavaScript
code so if you haven't tried Visual
Studio code for JavaScript you really
should use Visual Studio code for
JavaScript it does a much better job and
produces fewer false positives than
Visual Studio
I think of dub-dub-dub root as my bin
folder when I'm using typescript so
where do I compile things where do I
output them well place them into
dub-dub-dub route although bundled and
minified stuff it's like so it's like a
bin folder for me but for javascript and
typescript testing just a quick word on
how many test projects should you have
so I've worked on projects where there's
a web project and a core project and you
know some stats calculation project all
these things that are separated out and
people will say hey we need a test
project per production project what to
me is crazy because now I have to go
looking everywhere for tasks to me a
project typically when I want to create
a new project is because I want to
create a new unit of deployment or I
want to deploy that code differently
than lock code that's in other projects
and to meet unit tests don't have to be
deployed you just have to execute them
so if you want to put the unit tests for
three different projects that are part
of a system on the same test project
that's fine I like using X unit
there's various options now for dotnet
core but I still feel that X unit has
the is the best test Runner and the best
test language for writing unit tests so
it's lo ceremony has a good vocabulary
and it's my preferred testing framework
I try very hard to avoid mom so I'll
tell you a little story about how this
came around I started trying to do
test-driven development around 2004 and
I did it the traditional way so write
the test before you write the code then
you do red green factor and follow all
those steps did that for years and then
I felt like I got to the point where I
was comfortable writing testing code
without necessarily writing the test
first so yeah I started not following
that as religiously and that was fine
things still turned out fine but I was
still trying to think about unit tests
how do you unit test a controller well
the only way to unit tests is to make
sure you isolate that controller so it's
not working with any of your real
production services so you're giving it
fakes or stubs or mocks to that
controller and then you know what's
writing a lot of code but it seemed to
work pretty decent for c-sharp anyway
then first big angularjs project came
along and I tried to follow that same
philosophy angularjs controller how am I
getting unit tested well I'm gonna fake
out and mock out all the services that
get passed into that controller so me
and a couple other people on this team
we had this huge huge pile of unit tests
for our angular controllers and it was
so frustrating because every release
something would break unit tests would
pass something would break and that's
when I realized that trying to mock up
things create mock services and write
the unit test you're just programming in
expectations to your unit test that it
should behave the way you think it
should which is not really what I went
out out of the unit's house so I started
using this different approach on that
angularjs project and years ago and I
said look what if we didn't mock any
service except HTTP what if we wrote
tasks that called into the controller
and if the controller called into the
service that called another service that
eventually did an HTTP call what if it
went the whole way to the HTTP layer and
we just mocked out the data at the HTTP
layer and what I found was we wrote 30%
less test code we actually found bugs
when people checked in bugs into the
project before they got to production
and all of a sudden it just kind of
changed my view on
a lot that year and I started thinking
when I write a test now I'm not
necessarily going to think of it as a
unit test you know traditionally
traditionally at least to me a unit test
the reason we wanted to isolate things
so if someone checked in a bug out of
some low-level system component that it
didn't break all 1,000 or 200 or five
unit tests that are in the project it
only hit you know an isolated area of my
unit test that was testing that feature
but to me it's not worth it
I would rather write let's say ten lines
of test code that could fail for any
number of reasons inside of the system
because to me that's still an effective
test it provides a lot of value for me
and I only had to write ten lines of
code and I didn't have to mock a bunch
of stuff up where am I going with this
well it turns out with asp.net core
there's a couple interesting things you
can do one if you look in the Microsoft
repositories you'll see they have a
nougat specifically when they write unit
tests like how do they test middleware
or the useless thing called the asp.net
core test host the asp.net court éstos
kind of like the thing we used to do
with web api a few years ago where you
could host the web api in memory the
asp.net core test host provides me an
API where I can say let's create an
application with this startup and this
middleware and these services and then
send requests into it that don't
actually travel over the network so
everything happens inside of memory and
you can find tests inside of the
micropyle microsoft repository that look
like this let's create a server so
behind-the-scenes that's using this test
host and we're going to pass in some
options for the cookie authentication
services that the login password be here
we're going to send off HTTP messages to
that server they're just really
traveling through memory and it's gonna
go the whole way through the system it's
gonna travel through all my little ware
use services that are configured in
there and I'm gonna see that it comes
out with the status code and this header
and so forth another example excuse me
down here at the bottom create a server
use that server to create a client and
use that client to send off a get
request here I just want to make sure I
get back a status code to me those three
lines are beautiful because of those
three lines if that test passes
successfully
I have a higher degree of confidence
that the system is going to work versus
having 20 tests one that isolates the
logger and one that isolates the
middleware and so forth but this is my
personal philosophy and opinion you can
differ so where can you mock things out
well again I like mocking things out of
the data layer so you have to have the
abilities to switch abstractions between
let's say something that talks to cosmos
DB or MongoDB was something that just
holds data in memory and if you're using
entity framework and to be framework or
actually has this thing called the
in-memory provider so it simulates
sequel server or simulates a database
just by holding data in memory and no
it's not going to catch errors like
we've tried to insert records with
duplicate primary keys it doesn't
enforce database constraints but it is a
mock or a fake data layer that if I
configure that entity framework to be in
memory I can use all the rest of my
services inside of an application with
that test host and fire off request just
do something like save this new user or
save this invoice or edit something
everything happens in memory and I have
basically an integration test but it's
not an integration test where I have to
mess around with the UI it's an
integration task that goes through all
my middle where all my services
exercises everything right up to the
actual database layer and to me that
means writing a lot less test code and
having better bang for the buck for the
number of lines of test code that I have
so using the EF core in memory provider
pretty straightforward just have to say
to use an in-memory database and follow
a couple constraints when you're
instantiating this thing and that's good
so more integration tests fewer unit
tasks that's kind of my current motto
for some scenarios for some scenarios
not everywhere but heavy business logic
I still like to isolate and test that
have specific unit tests for that but to
me not having to test a controller in
isolation as beautiful because most
controllers are let's face it relatively
simple
I would rather test all the middleware
and the controller and everything down
to the database layer
c-sharp code so one of the things that
people are doing with asp.net core of
realize if they're taking the advantage
that asp.net core can execute on Linux
and so when they deploy they picked
Linux VMs or Linux app services and they
save 20 to 30 percent on that server
because they're not paying for the
Windows license but there's always a
little hiccup some little hiccups so
some things that we have run into and I
should back up and say if you're gonna
do that if you're going so to me one
let's talk about docker for a second to
me one of the advantages of using docker
containers is that I can develop on my
machine which is Windows but I'm
executing code that is in the production
environment which is Linux and there's a
big advantage to that because I can
catch problems sooner so I think in some
sense problems like this so just the
littlest things bite you and c-sharp
code you hard code new lines into an
application but new lines are really
different on Linux and Mac versus
Windows so instead of hard-coding / r /
r / n use environment new line it's
amazing how many people hard code paths
right so I need to build the path to
slash users slash temp slash and then I
have the filename or I have some base
holder name that's configurable and then
I have my file name how do I put them
together well I could just use this
string plus slash the string except that
slash right it's different on Linux vs.
Windows the proper way to do that use
path not combine also be aware that
environment variable names can be
different between the two environments
so those are the types of little things
that you can catch if you're using
docker to actually develop on Linux and
then finally me personally I despise the
async suffix on methods I think having
the word async here and having that word
async here is just too much icing so
even though the Microsoft recommendation
is that async Russia methods should have
the async suffix I don't do that and to
me I felt justified when I read this
quote from the inventor of C++ he said
for new features people insist on loud
explicit scent
I said yeah when a sink first came
around it was scary so we're just gonna
use the async word everywhere make sure
people are aware this is a sink but now
it's an established feature people want
a terse notation and I think I I
personally have reached that point I
wish we could just have everything be a
sync by default and not even have those
key words there but that's pipe dream so
I think it's fine that's used at you
sink suffix but you can differ with me
and that's all I have for you I thank
you for attending this is my email
address if you have some questions I
think we're out of time I'll hang out
and answer questions have a good
afternoon
thank you
[Applause]